like right now i'm super content with
just true that's the only thing was i
just like
born to believe i need to have so many
kids i don't know but i'm so happy with
just her so only time will tell
and with time comes another little one
for khloe kardashian she's officially a
mama of two
isn't that crazy
the reality star and her ex tristan
thompson are now a family of four after
welcoming their second child together a
baby boy via surrogate
of course the two are already parents to
four-year-old daughter true i am so
obsessed with her and i love it so much
i definitely don't think i would feel
incomplete if i didn't have more but
another one would just add
more love to the house and now that the
little guy's here we know coco's house
is full of all that goodness
it's exciting
now the timeline here is important
earlier this month coco's rep confirmed
to e.t that the pair's surrogate was
implanted in november but a month later
in december news broke of tristan's
latest cheating scandal where he
fathered a child with another woman it
all played out on season one of the
kardashians
everything is
an act of betrayal everything is a lie
everything is
manipulation it's deceit to tristan have
every opportunity to tell me yes was
tristan going to tell me if there wasn't
a baby involved absolutely not and that
shows a lot about his character the
entire thing is despicable a source
explained to e.t quote when the two were
on good terms they decided to move
forward with surrogacy near the end of
last year and then tristan was caught
cheating and since then chloe and
tristan haven't spoken outside of
co-parenting matters
i think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style the source also notes they're not
together and chloe will have the baby
full time but chloe wants tristan in
both the kids lives as much as he wants
to be we get along really really well
and so it's just easy to co-parent with
him
so how do tristan and chloe plan to move
forward with their new little bundle of
joy
well another source says the nba star
isn't trying to win her back
romantically and their relationship is
strained but tolerable
as for coco she's not letting anything
affect their growing fam quote she is
refusing to let any negativity take away
from her and her family's joy about this
exciting new addition i think it's
important to show people you can turn
your life around you can go through hell
and high water but you can still come
out and have a beautiful positive happy
life and despite everything that's
happened chloe holds nothing against
tristan it's a feeling she shared on the
not skinny but not fat podcast last
month there's so many good sides to him
as well but no one gets to see those
because they're all overshadowed by like
the personal stuff that's going on
between him and i he's always going to
be in my life because of true and he's a
great dad
and you know that's really all i need to
focus on is just his relationship with
true
congrats to coco and tristan on the
arrival of their baby boy
[Music]